if they put shoulder pads and cleats on
any same boat
it would be Randy Moss the big reason
everybody's on true Brisky is cuz he was
drafted in the same class as Moe Holmes
and Watson I know you know football
you've been watching the Jets all season
I don't know if that's football yeah
what up it is Sims and left cow one
thing that we really care about is not
just talking about the NFL but talking
about things that people seem to get
wrong right we see it all the time
setting the narrative straight yeah yeah
it really upsets you it does drive me
why are you upset you so much well
because a lot of the times the narrative
is false I'm finding out it's lazy
homework done by people in the media
where they just make a take and I don't
know if they've had any useful
information to back it up I'm gonna set
the grains yeah you go against them okay
earlier in the year and still now I see
people doubt in Mitchell true Brisky oh
it's off Oh Seattle game Green Bay game
there was a notion that Mitchell true
Biscay couldn't throw left yes for a few
weeks right here that was a popular
notion what's the truth what's the
against the grain the big reason
everybody's entre Brisky more than
anything is cuz he was drafted in the
same class as mahomes and watson and
everybody thoughts that and that's not
fair mahomes got drafted to a team that
was a playoff team watson essentially
got drafted to a team that was playoff
caliber Hallett had injuries to their
quarterback and other players he was a
true top 3 3 pick team he's got talent
and he's got talent around him and
that's why i can't draw a line in the
sand i just go he stinks that's not fair
one team that does not have talent right
the Buffalo Bills Shawn McDermott right
three wins thus far what Shawn McDermott
doing you almost think he should be up
for the coach of the Year candidate he
should be in the conversation for what
Shawn McDermott is doing good so great
yeah I mean first of all this team is
not good the other thing is he's a
defensive expert they're the number one
defense in football do you know how hard
it is to be the number one defense in
football when you don't have an offense
or a quarterback the quarterbacks have
been Peterman and Derek and exactly in
mature and a rookie Josh Allen they have
no receivers on the outside he manages
the game perfectly at a weekly
and I know he won't win coach of the
year s but he deserves to be in the conv
can I go against the gray of course you
can I'm seeing a lot of people right now
going oh my Holmes is good but Brees is
the MVP it's really like it's the one
thing he doesn't have in his career he's
really earned at this point mahomes is
gonna have more times this is not a
lifetime yes exactly
Drew Brees is not playing better than
Patrick mahomes Drew Brees cannot
complete half the passes that Patrick
mahomes does if you watch the game
against the Bengals
dump off to Camaro rights jump off to
Ingram right I would argue that probably
around 40% of Drew Brees is yards our
screens dumped off some slice they can
take into the house and Drew Brees is
awesome we're not being hate is great
but what to me and I think you're on the
right track here is when you're in the
MVP conversation you're urg person that
makes the team go people are hanging off
you and you're thrown exactly mahomes
makes the team Gus
Todd Gurley make us the Rams go yes I
would argue on the Saints the o-line and
the running back tandem make the team go
you would put Andrus peat in the MVP
conversation well I mean their offensive
line and their run game and then of
course Michael Thomas so I can't sit
there and go Drew Brees is the number
one reason that's making this team
successful it's a combination of things
and of course he's still playing really
good you've been noticing a trend of me
lately
yes and we're fixing it today good yeah
let's do that
hey what's up slugger Oh welcome
whoa don't touch me swag Nate Burleson
has it by the boatload it's flowing he's
got purposeful dirt on his jeans I've
never seen that before he's been making
fun of me lately because every guest we
have there's an issue with my handshake
huh and I don't want to show it to you I
need your help
but I need you to see what's been
happening lately break this down
pleasure
likewise definitely was fun again check
out Martellus a show last particular man
thank you did you see that I went with
it's red I've had I just have my
handshakes I've been good lately listen
first of all ya got to make eye contact
okay
and then you got a square your shoulders
you know saying I mean for you cuz oh my
god Chris I'm saying it's real Chris
that's all it is yes like with you you
gotta like square the shoulders where I
think you got to make a little eye
contact not too much - no they can how
high am I going with the hand yeah don't
go too high bring about shoulder yeah
right and then you want to make sure you
look at the elbow you look at the elbow
you need to look at it cause I mean if I
got a little sauce I know you for come
up here what's up baby I'm a contact
square and then focus on the other okay
all right all right so good all right
I'll need you to lick your lips like ooh
gee that was good though good contact
good good
then what but then we could not have
done this for a long so so the listen we
come in we come here yes and then
release and it has to be straight when
we come here though I saw you come here
it's not my fault yeah because you might
as well just go ahead and kiss his hand
like yes but you say you straighten it
up you know all right I mean I hope I
see you Nate today yeah you did no
listen I was trying to grab it you slid
out my finger pump that's why I ever do
this and all of our fingers have to
connect last one I'm on five here listen
if you ever worry you can always hold on
to it for a beat yes really
yeah miss are you good as a fan oh
that's too much oh man good and then I
just let go
yeah he's let go cuz I if you don't know
whether it's gonna be a snap pop an
extra hit you guys like to blow it up
afterwards you can just hold and be like
yo sup you got hey I appreciate you
having me on the show man next time we
got talks and politics
like that I'm a snapper I'm a snap yeah
because I went to text you I am I'm
sitting between I think the two most
employed people in NFL media radio shows
TV shows no but I mean what's it like
for both of you guys once you leave the
game you realize all right I got to bust
my ass and work just as hard in my new
craft so like every opportunity
like me being a rookie again and when I
was a rookie I walked in to the
Minnesota Vikings in I'm seeing daunte
culpepper in a Theismann fur and I'm
seeing Randy Moss swagged out with a
baggy suit and I'm like damn this is the
NFL these dudes pulling up and Bentley's
with spinners on it and I'm like baby
I'm a baby and I got to work not only to
make a name for myself but to like get
these guys attention and that was my
goal to get the Great's attention so
like what we do now is if we got to work
one two three four jobs we want to get
attentions out of the masses because
we're still working I would want to jump
off of something you said a few minutes
ago
where'd you brandy Moss yeah I was gonna
say you experienced the young Randy Moss
you experienced old random right the
first time I met Randy Moss I knew
immediately that if I got a attaboy pat
on the back from him I've arrived as a
right receiver
huh but I went about it the wrong way
because I was trying to get his
attention like a thirsty dude at the end
of the night like I was like all right
as soon as I hit him with this
icebreaker we're gonna be best friends
forever man and I remember one day I was
I was getting ready for practice and I
think was Jermaine Dupri it
he had a music video and he's wearing
the Marshall 88 Jersey so I'm like in my
little dorm room at Jenny comes like
this is it and I remember I was doing
conditioning and I'm standing next to
him I'm literally like gasps and myself
up like I do about to walk across the
bar and ask a girl for the number I was
like a Randy voice is cracking I'm a
grown man I was like did you see that
remain do pre video yeah add your Jersey
on there and he's running next to me he
looks at me he just keeps all right now
is crowd oh listen I wrote a girl a note
do you like me yes you know in the 5th
grade and she crumpled it up and threw
it at my face Oh Randy mom
hurt me more like my feelings were
crushed and I was like damn I blew it
and it was crazy is like once I started
making plays like that's when he came
and was like all right like I know you
love the game and I know you're one of
the good ones it's funny I think to hear
him say that because I don't think
people always realize that football
players can also be fan boys first time
Randy Moss came on the plane I missed
row 27 by the window and he said can I
sit here I was a
yeah yeah and I mean that's the way I
felt but the like Nate's I into the one
thing I learned from him in our hurry is
his perspective on the game was like
amazing he could almost see the game
almost like a quarterback you understood
offense and defense and you know he
understood when this play was stupid and
he wasn't gonna tell the coach that's a
stupid play Sims I see you know whatever
was yeah I mean and I just I really
enjoyed being around her Calvin is the
forgotten guy yeah if I'm creating a
player in Madden he's six five running a
four three and his name is Calvin
Johnson yeah but he's never mentioned in
the Jerry Rice tío Randy Moss top three
but I would argue his physically as
gifted as any of them if not more no
question I mean it's the same individual
that broke Jerry Rice's single-season
record yeah I watched him do it
I watched games where he'll put up a
buck 90 and we go to the meeting and
after a loss Shaun Jefferson was a
former player while receiver he was our
wide receivers coach he say Calvin I
need you to do more no I'm thinking like
damn what you want to do go for 250 and
Calvin would say anything
he's quiet you know his mother a doctor
daddy worked on the real world so he had
this blend of blue-collar and high IQ
and that was his approach to life and he
would just not as hit say alright coach
next guy and go put up 300 now Randy was
just pure speed and capsulated
if they put shoulder pads and cleats on
his same boat and he was actually a good
football player that can catch and track
the ball like no other
yeah it would be Randy Moss and Randy
Moss at the greatest late hands ever
even though coaches say don't panic
remember your cues don't give anything
away like we panic like we don't
remember our cues and we give everything
away like the ball is in the air you
start hearing your own breath and you go
from and if you're a really good DB I
know it's a small detail but you could
hear a guy breathing hard and then you
see his eyes go from here to here yes
and that right there is a cue that
something's coming right Randy would
like a look and the ball would be coming
in his face doesn't move his hands
doesn't move his breath doesn't move and
then right when it gets to him he's like
velcro like that's something that's you
might not see ever and that's not
something you coach
something that God said hey Randy I got
a little extra for you right you the man
that was awesome
Nate Burleson's the man he is I think
we're gonna have him back again I really
do good
you know else is the man every person on
the Rams and Chiefs roster it is the
game of the year it is the fourth time
since like 1990 that to nine and one
teams have faced off at this point of
the season how good of a game will this
be will this be 40 to 40 will it be
disappointing what's the Sims prediction
well I you know in games like this more
times they're not they don't live up to
the billing or the expectations of like
a shootout right this year has been
different though Rams Saints was really
good I know I know is actually patriots
was really it was extremely good I am
you made me bet I'm going to say we're
going to get a shootout we're gonna get
a 38:35 type of football game but what
happens a lot of times in these matchups
two defenses try different things too
because they go man we can't really stop
this group we got to do something which
sounds awesome yes sounds like a 70 yard
touch it can also make the offense lose
their rhythm to just going on they never
played this defense versus coverage but
either way I expect a ton of big-time
plays because it's good pie design yeah
and there's talent on both sides of the
ball and I like that both defenses take
risk yeah which will allow things do
exactly right question though for this
game right Rams Chiefs better big three
I think the hardest part about this is
picking your big three oh I look at the
Chiefs is your big three
mahomes Kareem hunt and he'll write is
it mahomes creme hunt in kelsey yes I'm
a Holmes Calci in Hill right who would
be your big three for the Chiefs were
you picking oh my gosh that's really
hard I don't even know what I mean
gosh alright well I'm gonna go golf
girly and cook hooks is that your set
for sure I mean yes we're your big three
for the Chiefs I gave you like 6s yeah
okay I mean that's obviously mahomes and
Tyree kill and I'm gonna go Kareem hunt
is the third and I'm sorry Chavez Kelsey
you're really awesome I know of those
two big threes yeah who you going I am
gonna go with the Chiefs and a close one
if I had to make the argument for the
Rams yes I agree with you I would take
my homeless or for anybody yep mahomes
yes Gurley is I believe the best of all
the six players out there okay I believe
that early is the number one pick yes
we're not valuing quarterbacks more I
think he's the most special
okay he's also the guy other than Tyree
kill that when he touches the ball I go
what's gonna happen yeah you do that
with my home's too so yeah don't forget
that
hi I'm Justin Forsett and you're
watching Sims and left go guys I'm
embarrassed ever since the dragon left
me hanging somebody hasn't picked a game
right for one to three weeks in a row
that's not acceptable for somebody that
likes left coal ox frankly we're locked
out
locked out Shawn call locksmith we are
in a historic place right here a a
locksmith you've been here in Midtown
for how long Dave 80-plus years 80 plus
years we're talking changing locks for
Mickey Mantle lead singer a kiss who
else Joe Montana Barbra Streisand Harry
Winston I'm a man of lakhs I'm a man of
left collogues and we have lost three
Thursday Night Football games in a row
Dave and I know you know football you've
been watching the Jets all season I
don't know if that's football it's a
good point but these two teams no
football
Seattle Green Bay in Seattle Seahawks
favored by two and a half I hear you got
a gambling guy that you asked for a tip
what did he say he says you got to go
with the Road Dogg here who's their
quarterback Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers
so it's two and a half points are you
confident in this I'm quite confident
are you confident enough to make it a
left go lock yes it's been locked Dave
lock-in it up takin the Packers on the
road plus the points two and a half Dave
Rodgers and two and a half point sounds
pretty good yeah I mean I don't know
it's Thursday Night Football they're on
the road in Seattle and what scares me
I'm gonna go I'm going Seahawks
okay I'm going against Dave The Rave
sorry negative ghostrider but yeah I
think the run game of the Seahawks yeah
against a not so good run defense of the
the Green Bay Packers that scares it
scares me if you take away the season
opener cuz that's not teams playing on a
short week the home teams are seven and
two the average margin of victory for
the Thursday Night Football games is 18
points
they're not even games since I'm seeing
these guys complain on Twitter the
winners like Steelers yeah saying I'm
still not right from the last game
these games stink thank you saying how
do we fix this what's the issue ok well
the biggest issue first of all is the
coaching right yeah it's a Thursday game
so there's not the coaches lose the
chance to be creative and add new things
into their game plan you don't get a lot
of practice time coaches aren't
comfortable to just I've heard a lot of
coaches say we're just gonna keep it so
exactly that's what they're gonna do
that's why it's not a great game well
yeah exactly right there were you sore I
was sore certainly I mean I'm a wussy
quarterback and on Thursday mornings I
woke up still sore after starting a
football game on Sunday so imagine how
Bobby Wagner feels urbe shod penny or
any other defensive player that's how to
make a lot of big you know contact
car-crash type hits something needs to
happen it does very much for Simms he's
out homies I don't know why I'm so
serious right now the lef koe and I
think I'm gonna go with Dave yeah I mean
Aaron Rodgers always scares Aaron
Rodgers
enjoy the games guys now I had a friend
that said I should go before hand so
that you it's like a downbeat of one
we're gonna do it huh you make you know
like a and then go in don't so I'm gonna
listen to you you're not playing double
bit like what you said hey what's up
homies thanks for watching subscribe to
the BR YouTube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here we
have a lot of other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square
he ruined it it was really close